[Applause]
now james johnson wants a piece of
stevenson goes inside with the left hand
nine in the court stevenson the pacers
out of the timeout with the lead he's
gonna let it fly again for
long as they're going three that screen
he's making shots
stephen set up and two more
a 14 point first quarter for lance
stevenson
stevenson in the corner for three count
it again
i mean you can't do anything but laughs
he's got the entire [ __ ] adventure and
they're laughing because he's he's
basically styling as he's making these
shots you cannot script this
set the screen with a bonus on him and
if that in fact is the case there's
nobody at the rim
final 10 seconds of the quarter
[Applause]
stevenson on the wing
lets it fly for three got it you can't
ask for a better debut than that
i don't care what you expected you can't
ask for more than that
a 20-point
first quarter for lance stevenson
[Applause]
indiana he's back
what a show in the first 12 minutes from
stevenson and the indiana pacers
[Applause]